hey this is preshtal Walker
so we have five squares in a two by two
grid and one square on the middle of
this two by two grid each square has the
side length equal to one
this arrangement of five squares is
circumscribed by a circle
the question is what is the radius of
the circle
I think Charlie from Australia for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
there are many many ways to solve this
problem and I will present three methods
method one right triangles
so consider the square on the right side
this side is a chord of the circle
now consider the two squares in the two
by two grid on the left side
they're two sides together will be a
chord of the circle
now if we take the perpendicular
bisector of the chord on the right it
will pass through the center of the
circle
if we take the perpendicular bisector of
the cord on the left it will of course
pass through the center of this two by
two grid and it will also pass through
the center of the circle
so if we combine these perpendicular
bisectors together we'll end up that
we're just going to go through one line
and this will be the diameter of the
circle
so the center of the circle will be
somewhere along this diameter
so let's say the center point is p
we will then construct a right triangle
on the left side the hypotenuse of this
right triangle will be equal to R
we'll now construct a green triangle on
the right side
so one side length will be half the side
length of the square so this will be
equal to 0.5
and then the hypotenuse of this right
triangle is the radius of the circle so
its length will be equal to R
so let's focus on these right triangles
so let's say the distance from the left
side of this two by two grid to the
center p is equal to X
now if we take the total horizontal
distance of the two by two grid plus the
one square that will be a total distance
of three
so we extend this distance here
this will be equal to 3 minus X
from the blue right triangle we have x
squared plus 1 squared is equal to r
squared from the green right triangle we
have the square of 3 minus X Plus 0.5
squared is equal to r squared
we'll expand the binomial to get nine
minus 6X plus x squared plus 0.25 is
equal to r squared and this simplifies
to be 9.25 minus 6X plus x squared is
equal to r squared
so now let's subtract the second
equation from the first so that we
cancel out x squared and r squared
we are left with 6X minus 8.25 is equal
to 0 which means that X is equal to
1.375
from here we will substitute this into
the first equation that x squared plus 1
squared is equal to r squared
so this will give the square of 1.375
plus 1 is equal to r squared and
therefore 11 over 8 squared plus 1
squared is equal to r squared making 11
over 8 into 121 over 64. we then make 1
into 64 over 64 so we have a common
denominator of 64. so this means that r
squared is equal to 185 divided by 64.
taking the square root and just taking
the positive length we get that R is
equal to root 185 all over 8 which is
approximately equal to 1.7
and that's one way you can solve the
problem
so here is another method
we can solve this using the formula for
the circum radius of a triangle
so what triangle are we going to use
let's construct the following triangle
ABC where a b is two sides of the square
and C is the upper point of the square
on the right
so now what we'll do is we'll drop a
perpendicular from the point C to the
side a b call this point d
this will bisect the side of the square
so it will be lengths of 0.5 and 0.5
now the height of this DC will be equal
to 3 because it is three squares long
so here's the formula for the circum
radius it's equal to the product of the
three sides of the triangle divided by
four times the area of the triangle so
we just need to calculate the sides of
this triangle ABC and the area of this
triangle
so side a b is equal to 2 that's two
side lengths of the square
what about side AC
well consider the right triangle ADC we
know that one leg is 0.5 and the other
leg is three so the side AC will be the
hypotenuse so that'll be the square root
of 0.5 squared plus three squared and
this simplifies to be the square root of
37 all over 2.
we can do the same thing for side BC
because we have a right triangle BDC
BD is equal to 1.5 then DC is equal to
3. so we have the square root of 1.5
squared plus three squared and this
simplifies to be 3 times the square root
of 5 all over 2.
now what's the area of this triangle so
if we take a b as the base we take CD as
the height and we divide this by two so
it'll be 2 multiplied by 3 all over 2
and that works out to be 3. so all
that's left is to substitute into this
formula we have the product of the sides
of the triangle divided by four times
its area and we do some simplification
and this once again gets us to our
answer of the square root of 185 over 8.
so that's another way you can solve the
problem
now here's method three using coordinate
geometry
so let's set up the following
coordinates
we'll let the x-axis be along the
diameter of this circle
and then we'll let the y-axis be along
the left side of this two by two grid of
squares
so the point a will be at zero comma one
and the point c will be three units over
and half the unit up so it will be a
three comma 0.5
now construct the chord AC
so now let's get rid of the square so
that we can focus on what's important
the x-axis is along the diameter of the
circle
then if we take the perpendicular
bisector of the chord AC that will pass
through the center of the circle
so the intersection of the perpendicular
bisector of AC with the x-axis will be
the center of the circle
so let's construct that and figure out
its coordinates
so we take the perpendicular bisector of
AC which will pass through the midpoint
M of AC
since we have coordinates it's easy to
figure out the coordinates of M it'll be
the average of the coordinates of A and
C so this will be 1.5 comma 0.75
the intersection with the x-axis will be
the point P which is the center of the
circle and let's say its coordinates are
P comma zero
so now we calculate the slope of the
chord AC
this will be the change in the Y
coordinates divided by the change in the
x coordinates which is 1 minus 0.5
divided by zero minus 3 which is equal
to negative 1 over 6. so the chord AC
has a slope of negative 1 over 6.
the perpendicular bisector will have the
opposite reciprocal of that so the slope
of the line passing through PM will be 6
because that's the opposite reciprocal
of negative one over six
so now we can calculate the slope
between the points P and M
we can see here that the vertical change
will be 0.75 minus zero so the
horizontal change will be 1.5 minus p
and we need the rise over the run to be
equal to 6. so a 0.75 divided by 1.5
minus p is equal to 6 and we can solve
this equation
so that P is equal to 1.375
now that we know the coordinates of the
center of the circle we can figure out
the radius because that will be the
length of AP
so we just use the distance formula here
so with the square root of the square of
0 minus 1.375 plus the square of 1 minus
0.
this exactly works out to be the square
root of 185 divided by 8 which is
approximately equal to 1.700 and that's
the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign